c'était il y à un mois faciliter
l'expérience patients c'est ce qu'on
veut pour les femmes le ministre de la
santé annonçait la fin du test pap
traditionnel qui sera progressivement
remplacé par un test moins invasif le
test vph
une nouvelle bien accueillie mais qui
n'a jamais été transmises aux principaux
concernés oui le gouvernement veut mais
nous on n'est pas prêt sur le terrain
donc le décalage qui kispert c'est un
peu c'est un peu décevant et c'est
l'enjeu principal des gynécologues sont
peu confiants de voir les test vph dans
un avenir rapproché sur le terrain on ne
rien n'y a pas de danse ont fait des pas
de terre prévu donc c'est super un
ballon qui se dégonfle dr bouchard
traite des femmes atteintes du vph
chaque jour elle demande l arrivée de
ces tests depuis des années malgré
l'annoncé de québec elle croit que ce
sera encore très long avant de pouvoir
les utiliser je passe du cabinet ou
peut-être début mai mais toi si on est
chanceux le ministère de la santé et des
services sociaux dit vouloir définir le
déploiement des tests au cours des
prochains mois et les femmes demandent
est-ce que je vais avoir le nouveautés
et ses rivaux mon bureau me faites vous
de nouveau dès ce
vous êtes encore l'ancien thèse qui est
moins sensible donc des textes 50% -
vision mais selon dr bouchard le temps
presse trois canadiens sur quatre seront
en contact avec le vph dans leur vie le
virus est responsable de la quasi
totalité des cancers du col de l'utérus
une femme sur 168 sera atteintes de ce
cancer au cours de sa vie un cancer qui
est un taux de mortalité de près de 25%
chaque retard comprend la plupart du
temps il n'y a pas de séquelles mais
pour cette patiente le keeper des
séquelles bl c'est dramatique pour elle
mise à part le dépistage rapide l'autre
méthode afin d'éviter les complications
liées au vph c'est la vaccination
le vaccin gardasil
mais le québec vaccine dans les écoles
seulement depuis 2008 et à cette époque
là c'était juste les jeunes filles qui
recevaient les doses une dose de vaccin
gardasil
ça coûte environ 220 dollars et ça en
prend 1,3 pour avoir une protection
maximale les gynécologues mail et donc
afin de rendre ce vaccin est couvert par
la ramq eu ici alexandre les radio
canada québec